and I'm sick and tired of this [ __ ]
debate maybe need to respect women
period so you should respect women I am
a woman I just became a woman it's just
like are you [ __ ] kidding me
hundreds of people in downtown Dallas
today for the 4th annual women's March
going on now in our national government
we're going back to the 50s I mean
there's other methods of showing up like
voting and stuff but I feel like would
make even like more of a difference but
at the Dallas women's March and March is
all over the country and all over
internationally are not about Trump
for years in the women's March target
hasn't changed ah the fourth annual
women's March this year in Dallas Texas
we set up to change my mind table and
some of the crew even joined in the
March
[Music]
hello ladies no debate is a trap
now to be clear we did have some great
rational sit-down conversations and
we'll be airing some more of those
Wednesday but before that I'd like to
draw your attention to the felony
assaults committed starting with this Z
[Music]
nope
[Applause]
captured the flag sweetheart glad that's
over now we can get back to civil
rational conversations devoid of any
future felony assaults right right
a woman who is told if you're assaulted
please go to the authorities they won't
handle it and then someone in a
privilege of power let's say a cop or an
attorney or whatever they ask the
question well what were you wearing that
night that permeates he's wait we'll
have a conversation afterward may need
to respect women period so you should
respect women I am a woman so [ __ ] you
if you don't think so
I don't really have time for this I and
I don't have time my on stage you're
going to let me speak because here's my
truth I've been breaking four times I've
known women that have been raped
multiple times gruesomely and he'll dare
you sit up here and try to say the women
aren't worth of respect appearances I
just became a woman it's just like are
you [ __ ] kidding me people don't even
respect me period and I'm only I'm
already black so it's just like yeah
that already goes against me anyways but
still my lease of living garbage ass
dumpster fire trash gum on the bottom of
my shoe oh my god I wish I had a tissue
for the flood I would oh when I suggest
it's your behavior not because you're
black or a woman I'm sorry I'm sorry can
I stop here this guy stop here can I
stop here please
she has just made a statement about
being assaulted which is very vulnerable
and it's very scary to do she just come
here tell me just call me a piece of
[ __ ] so I'm saying that's she sorry my
mistake so when did she go from male
privilege to female privilege because
she just said she only became a female
recently it wasn't okay the approach
that she made but it also wasn't okay to
antagonize her
if we're gonna have a conversation let's
go back to what we originally know I
think it's important because I think
that's an example of female or trans
privilege right there because you
weren't helping the situation so I
brought us back well I'm not helping the
situation is about being truthful these
matters I'm going to finish saying my to
grab your truth
let's hope it's that truth and not what
that lady was saying thank you I
appreciate that yeah I believe it's a
man that woman very upset made very
valid points made zero valid points so
let me ask you this to find woman a
woman what is a woman we're talking
about men's privilege rape culture to
find woman for me so I don't get it
wrong well a woman is any person who
defines yourself as if you're looking at
biologically speaking a woman is someone
who has female parts her anatomy is that
of a vagina and having just female parts
just biologically female parts obviously
our friend there wouldn't have that so
would that be a student okay so but
that's your definition of it that's one
definition of it what's your definition
of it so that way I'm not stepping over
any bounds if you were definitely any
person who uses the pronouns he I mean
I'm sorry she and who identifies as such
okay I respect what they identify
themselves out it's not an example of
female privilege there if that's a man
we treat them very differently and I'm
sure you're aware of this oh yeah it's
accountability between men oh absolutely
a country where a guilty until proven
innocent
it innocent yes we'd be rotting in a
jail but I I know I know of a story just
recently and I'm sorry I can't come up
with I can't say the name come on that's
an appropriate sweetheart
you feel better oh are you offended by
what I said no I just don't think it's
necessary
aren't you just feeding into it you do
realize that's a violent crime correct
you're fine ah so because there's no
damage done fine okay recently that
doesn't bother you what if that were a
man because that's a woman wouldn't
bother you this moment okay I don't I
think you might need to check your own
privilege and bias hey don't forget to
subscribe and hit all notifications on
the notification bell because just
hitting the bell isn't enough anymore
another installment of change my mind
Wednesday stay tuned for that and in in
this one hopefully no hobos lunchboxes
get stolen and or thrown I said I said
hobos bows